the blue jays looking to keep the good
times rolling right now they have won
four in a row 11 of their last 14 trying
to sweep the orioles
on trade deadline day in the blue jays
if you didn't hear it about 10 minutes
ago a move was made as they acquired
starting pitcher robbie ray
from the arizona diamondback and chase
anderson is going to make his fifth
start of the season first time he's ever
pitched against the orioles so he will
try to build on that great outing he had
last time out that'll get a 406 hitter
to the plate jose iglesias and tandare
takes the lead off second 2-2 pitch on
the way to iglesias
right field base hit santander on his
way home and the orioles lead at one
nothing
just what the doctor ordered right there
iglesias
the league's best hitters on the road
continues his uh success keating of
course led the international league with
131 punchouts so expect him to strike
out a few guys
got him looking
bang bang boom see you later
there you go establish that fastball
right out of the gate santiago espinel
the blue jay shortstop number nine
hitter takes ball one up high
that's it well to left field
monk castle back and makes the catch
nice play by ryan montcastle as santiago
espinel
smoked one to left field yeah he jumped
all over that mount castle has been a
little shaky in the outfield uh gets a
nice jump on this and really shows his
athleticism take a look that's been all
getting all over trying to beat mount
castle deep pretty good line there and
then the leap the blue jays have
reportedly just acquired jonathan vr
from the miami marlin
late call but it's called strike three
at the knees renato nunez strikes out
boy that's more of a slider there and
it's put the heart of the plate it was
down around the knees two down two in
scoring position for kevin bishop who's
over two
and vichy over the ground ball long
throw is high and two runs are going to
score on the play
should have been the end of the inning
and instead the blue jays catch another
break and take a two to one lead
wow
the orioles have had a rough
series
in the field and this is a routine
ground ball hanzo alberto has committed
just one air this season but you can see
he airmails new yes on ahead two strikes
that ball hit pretty well to left field
the dive but no catch
around third is alberto he will score
and the orioles have tied it
on a double
by anthony santander
got it out over the head of guriel out
there who seemed to be playing pretty
shallow yeah yeah didn't respect
santander's power at all hanzer alberto
getting things going with a single three
fast balls in a row he's just seen it
too much and he does stay on top of the
elevated heater this one on the outer
third he beats guerrielle jr
there's the bouncer they'll come to the
plate it's there in plenty of time and
he's out
alberto to severino two down
nice play right there by hanzer alberto
runner going
and they got him on a one hopper
what a nice tag by iglesias as he hangs
on to the snow cone
probably get this thing reviewed as
fisher was called out
out of there to end the inning so we're
playing extra innings when we come back
the originals have a runner on second
with nobody down extra innings in
buffalo top of the 10th one-two pitch on
the way
golfed in the air to right field
hernandez now coming in
still coming in
here comes the runner here comes the
throw
he gets him what a throw by tay oscar
hernandez
forte oscar
made a troll much like that in baltimore
he has another double play a 9-2 double
play danny jansen did a good job of
hanging in there putting the tag on
mason williams
santander out at second base to start
the 11th
as well that's it well
and over the head all the way to the
wall in left field curiel picks it up
santander is home
and on at second with a double
jose iglesias
there you go no small ball this time
yeah well beautiful swing right there
anthony silent time there of course
starting the inning out at second base
they are taking everything they can do
to win this game first pitch to holiday
he swings and sends it out towards right
field heading back back towards the wall
it falls into the deep corner turning
third here comes iglesias the throw is
cut off and the orioles an rbi single
for bryant holiday they get insurance
and take it 4-2 top of the 11.
little looper off the end of the bat
will get down for a base hit and guriel
keeps it alive
as he drives in grichik to make it a one
run game and now rowdy teles is going to
come up
that's hit well right field
santander on the run can't get there
racing into third
are they sending them to the plate yes
they are and he's tagged out in the
orioles win
they got him at the plate
not this time for the blue jays
wow these guys are anything but boring
mike
it's never easy quite a play right there
uh rowdy to leise with the big hit damn
chuck it back in but where's the cutoff
man there's nobody in line iglesias
comes firing over at a beautiful playoff
balance and a nice job by cisco no way
you're making it to home yeah no tag no
replay needed here